Okay. We are on and we are live. Okay. So welcome everybody to another Zoom call. It is December.
What is it? December 20th? 20th today. Wow. So Mary Christmas to everybody.
I will talk to you again before Christmas. Both of you. So Mary Christmas. Hopefully everybody's
going to have a great time with her family. So let's open it up for questions that you have right
on before I get to the ones that everybody asked online. I don't know whether we call it in
right at this point, but I'll start. What I want to ask you is maybe you could help to
clarify the process of detoxification in relation to the right machine. So that's kind of my
question is how those two work together to do what they do. And I, Dr. Clancy, this is Carol,
David's wife, and to add to that as David and I talk on, you know, when we were listening to Michelle
talk about the clocky animal, you know, we were understanding like sometimes when some people
would say they could hold the clocky animal in their body for six minutes and then Michelle would say
things like, well, that's good at me, but it circulated in this way in your in your body. And then
we were sort of understanding a little bit more about like how things, you know, are then eliminated.
And so just in general with the detoxifying with David, you know, with what the right is doing as well
with what the pharmaceuticals are doing. How is his body being detoxified? Okay, so detoxification
takes place in every single cell. So what's going on inside the cell is enzymatic processes and
enzymes are made by different feeds. So that's where we want to look at genetic defects that people
might have because they could have restrictions on intracellular detoxification pathways if they
don't make enough duperoxide dispotation, if they don't make enough catalysts or they don't make
enough glutathione or Nerf2 or keep one. So those are all the intracellular detoxification pathways.
If they don't make those, there are certain herbs and different nutraceuticals that can help push those
pathways. So that's why you would take different nutrients and many of those nutrients are found in
good foods. That's why, you know, you eat a lot of change your diet to eat prepared foods and
McDonald's and things like that. You're eating good whole foods and good vegetables because they have
those nutrients that will help support and push those pathways. No, the detoxification that takes place
in certain cells depends on what the thing that it is that you're detoxifying but many of those things
are, are, are, canalyzed in a certain way that they're made notoxic. So, for instance,
superoxide ion is canalyzed by superoxide dispotase to turn it into, to add a H2
group up to it, and you end up with hydrogen peroxide that is
canalyzed further by canelase and glutathione rooted into
water that you that excrete.
But that is excrated. So some some intracellular toxins are
excreted then through your kidneys via so it's picked up in
that extracellular space through your live system carried to
the blood and it excreted through the kidneys.
Other chemicals like pesticides and heavy metals and such are
keylated and excreted through your liver into your colon.
And that's why it's so or that you're not constipated, because
constipation can lead to reabsorption of those toxins.
Okay. So the detox pathways are complicated in a sense. But if
you just think of it, we got to get things out of the cell, it
goes out of the cell into the space between the cells, then you
need a good healthy lymphatic system to drain that area. That's
where exercise comes in because the lymphatic system doesn't
have a heart that's pushing it. It's only moving through the
live system through action of contraction of the muscles. So
you know, getting some exercise contracting the muscles, even if
you're sitting in a chair doing isometric exercises, getting
contraction of the muscles help moves the lymph. That's where
doing like rebounded, but those little trampolines can be
beneficial. Yeah. So you're getting it through the live to
either to the kidneys to be excreted or to the liver to be
excreted into the bowel. And that's where sawdust can be
helpful too, because then you're excreted extra cellular
matrix fluid through the pores of your skin. So you're bypassing
the liver and you're bypassing the kidneys would take some
pressure off the kidneys in the liver. So the benefit of doing
confianabas is it just helps support the liver detoxification. So
it helps deliver dope. Yeah. So does that help answer that
question? Yeah, it does. Absolutely. And how does the
live machine, how does that fit into this scenario? The
right machine doesn't specifically detoxify, but the right
machine is so depending on what program you're doing. So if
we're running cancer programs, we're helping the body kill
cancer cells. So in that sense, it is a detoxification, you
could say, we're getting rid of cancer cells. And there are
live programs on there that can help stimulate live flow, but
it's not going to stimulate flow like doing rebooted or
something like that. It's just going to be the it's the
frequencies. So that is the right machine understand is using
frequency medicine. So everything in your body is frequency.
So if you can stimulate the frequency of the liver, you're
going to help the liver work better. So those cells are going
to work better. And that's going to support the detox pathways
that way. So in every single person's program, there's liver
programming, because when you're killing, when you're killing
cancer, you have to support detoxification. So I put in
everybody's program, let no liver frequencies because we
want to support that. So your overnight program is supporting
detoxification, but it's supporting it by number one, killing
cancer, number two, helping stimulate the liver and its own
frequency. So the liver works better.
So we're using frequency medicine with the rife, we're using
chemistry with like a nutrient like milk, thistle that would
help the liver or pond one that would help the pond one
pathway, or there's two that would help the nerve two pathway
were eating really good foods is chemistry to the cells to help
support those pathways. The rife is using frequencies that
using other tools like exercise and rebooting is helping stimulate
levatic flow. And then the sound is helping you use the
skin as a detoxification pathway.
Yeah, that's very good. And if we were recently googling
some YouTube on the rebounder, we don't have one, but what we
wanted to get action on one, because also, since David had
that we that cardiac experience, we were not certain how how
much or how little he could even say, do want to rebounder. So
we've just begun to explore that that's cool, because it does
look like it's a great way, like you said, to do the whole
lymphatic, you know,
well, another good tool that you might consider is are those
vibration plates, and you have a picture of them in your
three ring binder.
In the diet part of the back of the diet part, there's
information on the rebounder and other helps with detox
pathways. And one of them is a vibration plate. So those
vibration plates that you stand on or the ones that you sit
and just put your feet on vibrations, relation into your feet
helps stimulate a little microscopic bustle contraction. And
that helps with levatic detoxification as well.
That's a great tip. We missed that, but we'll look at the
binder as soon as the call is over. Yeah, that's great. Thank
you. Yeah, I definitely missed that part of it, but we'll check
that out for sure. And not somebody else has got another question
or you've got your right chin or your right. Yeah, I have
another question for you. Oh, yeah.
Stay with the right machine.
What I'm finding is that I'm currently getting up with leg
discomfort, leg pain at times in the pelvis, the size, the
front, the back of the thighs. And is there can I, can I
introduce more right machine during the course of the day? Is
there a point where there's too much?
Good question. So no, the only time that there you could do
too much rifing is if you are doing too many bacterial programs
and not to get too technical, but certain bacteria, Graham
negative bacteria have lipopolysaccharides in their cell
membrane, right? If you kill them too fast, you liberate them
and that constipulated immune reaction. So if person is auto
immune, they could kill too fast and they could have a
hurt cyber reaction. Most my kids, we're not talking about that
with our kids or patients. So no, you can run other programs
during the day. You got a lot of programs out there, you
could run pain programs, you could run healing programs,
whatever you want to run, you can't overdo it.
Okay. All right. And and also with as far as the bulb, you
must have answered this question many times in the past.
We're talking with Michelle last week, we're talking about
this subject in a little bit. She was asking how close I
keep the balls to my body. I said, you know, we're in a few
inches. Maybe you want to bring a little bit closer. Any
concern, any issue about actually putting it directly to the
skin. No, you could struggle with the bulb. Yeah,
absolutely. Okay. All right. All right. I'll introduce a
more right. Sure.
Dr. Connor, I will miss the call last week, but even was
talking with Michelle about this pain and this thing about the
pain that time he had figured out maybe that pain in the
pelvis and the pelvis versus the bone versus the muscle.
Is there anything else you want to ask David the doctor
plans to say more about differentiating this, trying to
help you as an individual under the end with a penis?
Um, some of the question was, um, I can't, I cannot distinguish
what don't painted versus a pain that come into the muscle
from the tissue around the muscle ligaments. Okay. So what
of the differential diagnoses is paid source would be? Okay,
so do I have paid upon rest? Yes, I have paid even what a
dot movie that I'm sitting at the chair, I have this deep
drop. Okay, is it worse when you contract the muscle? No, is
it worse when you're when you are when you're like contracted
under a load? No, then it's probably not muscle and it's
probably not tended, at least it's not tended of the muscle
that you are contracting. So a muscle paid and a tendon paid
will be will typically be worse upon a load and will be
less of a disuse. So if a bone pain will typically feel like
a deeper pain. And will feel like, you know, most people have
hurt, you know, a damaged a joint or sprayed an ankle or hurt
a muscle in the past, this deep bone pain will feel you'll
say, this just feels different. So it's a little bit less
distinguishable that way. And a deep bone pain will be can be
painful upon not use. So as where a muscle paid, if you have an
acute muscle injury, it can be paid for all the time. But as
time goes on and you don't have a muscle, you know, it's not an
acute injury anymore, typically a muscle, muscle pain will
be called down when you're not using it. That's that's kind
of what's happening. It's only under load by climbing stairs
or walking today. I could feel it in my legs. And when I get
up from a city position, when I'm getting out of my vehicle, my
my muscle leg muscles from the knees up feel pretty tight.
Then they loosen up after a little bit. It's still there. But
at night time, I can't feel it. Okay, so what let's let's say
if I have cancer, but pesticides to the bone, what are the
signs of that can be the deep bone paid at night? So it's not
worse when I walk it around, it's not worse when I'm walking
upstairs, it's it's usually you feel it more when you're at
rest because you're not, you're not movie, you're not
thinking about other things that you're just sitting there and
then you feel this deep bone pain.
And that's not always what I'm just saying, I'm just walking
through a differential diagnosis picture of that.
I find that it really is forming and I just kind of think that
maybe what's happening with David is the combination of that
he has that deep bone pain, which is the task as I can
turn into the bone and also because we haven't been able to
work in the past month, I think because he's being said he's more
sedentary than some of the pain and stuff he's feeling in his
legs is because he hasn't been moving those muscles.
Absolutely. So you could get a combination, especially if you've
bed used to be an active, no, you're not as active. You could get
this disuse paid where you know, you are kind of fully don't
have shape, you could say.
Yeah, yeah, maybe it is a combination that way.
Okay, all right, well, that's that's the health for now.
Okay, any other questions from anybody else either?
I've got a question.
What is the how often can you hyperbaric treatment?
Um, you can do hyperbaric treatment every day.
For how long?
You could do hyperbaric treatment every day for your rest of your
life. I mean, how long each I would do an hour.
Okay, I would do it.
If you're going to do it every day, I would do it an hour.
I wouldn't do it a longer than did you get your unit?
Yes. Okay. Did you start using it?
Yes. Just for a half hour though, because I wanted to check with
you first. Yeah, you could go up to it or you usually could bump
up to it or right away.
Okay. Thank you. Yeah, you'll like that.
That will be good.
And the benefit of hyperbaric is is enter the more often you do it.
Um, the problem that people have with hyperbaric is that, you know,
sometimes it takes 30, 40 sessions before you even start seeing any benefit.
So you the more often you do it, you'll see benefit.
What's the concern about the eyes?
I keep seeing that popping up under the type of chamber that you have,
you won't have any issues with the eyes.
Okay.
So if you have symptoms in like your eyes hurt or your
sinus is hurt, then then just drop down the time about you probably have
like an infection, um, a sinus infection.
So that's where you can do the hyperbaric chamber if you have sinus infection
or polyps like me.
I can't do it.
It's just too painful.
I can't pressurize, um, or if you have like an ear infection, you,
you'll know because you'll start to pressurize.
You're like, ah, turn this off and you'll answer the thing.
So it's, uh, you, you'll know, yeah, no pain.
It's been great.
Okay. Perfect.
So, so Doc, who's using why, why would someone use a hyperbaric chamber
for instance?
So hyperbaric, hyperbaric chamber is great.
For cancer, great for Lyme, great for brain function, all cybers, injury,
um, healing from wounds, probably the most common,
the most common use of hyperbaric chamber is a lot of professional athletes have
their own hyperbaric chamber.
So it's just another therapy that is highly beneficial.
Um, so this, this, this, John, who just called in and asked
in about, uh, is, is chamber, was that a suggestion from, uh, from you from the
office?
Yeah.
Well, I always, this is a chamber's are expensive.
So, yeah, something everybody could afford, but they're, they're great,
they're great if you could do it, if you could afford it.
That I always asked for you purchase a chamber.
You go do some sessions at somebody on the office so that you know that you
could tolerate it.
Yeah.
Yeah, because you tend to, you have to have, you can't have issues with
claustrophobia and I, I've had patients and go, Oh, no, why don't have any issues
so they get in there and they freak out.
So surely, surely, okay, okay, we're good to know, well, I'm not familiar with that,
but okay, thank you.
Okay, so let's get into our talk today.
This might answer some questions and we'll take questions at the end.
So we got mixed questions today and I already covered the questions of the
rice that I wanted to cover and I want to talk about some other things.
I and I, we want to talk about that.
We want to talk about zikid copper.
So first, I and I, I and I is a mineral that we get in our food.
Now, you know that part of the problem with our food is that you can only get
any mineral in a vegetable if there's minerals in the soil for the vegetables
to pull it to its, to its root in order to be in the vegetable itself.
So if you're growing something in depleted soils, you're not going to have those
minerals in, in the thing that you're growing, it's impossible.
That's why I am not, I am not for hydroponic garnity.
Even though, wow, I could grow vegetables in my basement with this hydroponic
garden deed set that I bought.
Really?
Well, you know, add some phosphorus and nitrogen to that, that water.
And you will grow a nice, pretty little carrot, but it's not going to have any
nutrients in it.
So what good is that?
So you have to, that's where organic is so important.
The problem with iodine is that many of our soils in the Midwest are depleted
of iodine.
So we can't have low iodine levels.
Now, it's not as bad as it used to be years ago because people are not just eating
locally anymore by organic vegetables that I got in the grocery store today.
We're not grown in Minnesota.
So they were grown in another state that has more iodine in the soil.
But tested for iodine, especially for breast cancer patients, maybe a good idea.
I don't recommend this for everybody, but for breast cancer patients,
this is more of an option because iodine deficiencies have been shown to be at
least a piece of some breast cancer cases.
So that's a test that we may want to run if you have breast cancer.
Copper and zinc is another thing that I'm starting to run more tests of
copper and zinc because there's some new data coming out that high copper levels
can feed cancer.
So when I'll put a video together on this in detail, but we don't want high copper levels
and there's some new data coming out that low zinc levels can be a problem
and can be responsible for giving relatively high copper levels.
So you want to do a test that measures both copper and zinc and then look at
the ratio of zinc to copper or copper to zinc because that is important with cancer.
So we are starting to run those blood tests.
And if you want to do that, let me know.
It's a blood spot test that I said down to you and you prick your figure and put
the blood drops on this little card.
You let it dry and you spill it in and it's a really nice little test to measure
your zinc copper ratio.
In that test, we also do a urine test and we get iodine in that same test and some
other things like lead and mercury and other metals that could be causing problems too.
But that's a nice thing to look at.
I was at a seminar this weekend.
That's where I did those one videos that you saw that I put up on Facebook.
And if you haven't watched those, I really recommend that you do.
But zinc and copper levels, oh, also somebody made a comment.
I don't remember that they missed last Zoom call.
Remember all the Zoom calls, any new videos that I create, any new information
that I create, I'm putting it on your Facebook page first.
So all you miss a Zoom call, watch it again.
It'll be posted up on this Facebook page.
I love going to seminars because I get to rub shoulders
with like-minded doctors.
And this one was important because there was a lot of cancer stuff at the seminar
that one of my colleagues was talking about a patient
that he had that had uncontrolled prostate cancer that had spread to the bone,
had spread to the lung, it spread to the liver.
And it was his PSA, it was just flying off the roof
and it was not looking good for this young, this older man.
And he had done some research on zinc and he decided to do an experiment
because this guy was at the end of his role.
He was willing to try anything and he injected zinc under MRI
into this man's prostate, into the man's cancer on his ribs,
and into the man's cancer on his lungs.
He didn't, I don't think he had it as liver.
And in all the areas, the cancer shrug literally within a couple weeks.
So that was like super probacid.
Problem is, is that's not necessarily, quote unquote, legal to do that.
So find somebody to do that.
I mean, because if you're going to try to get it into the prostate,
you would have to do it under MRI.
So this guy was out of country, out of the country that did this.
So he could get by with it, but you couldn't find anybody in the states to do that.
Now, if you had breast cancer, you could get a needle injected into your breasts.
That would be pretty easy, but to get it into, you know, a deep organ,
you'd have to do it under MRI or ultrasound, and that's not quite as easy.
But that got me thinking, okay, so you could use a driver like DMSO with zinc.
So using a driver like DMSO with zinc, that's a possibility.
So if we look at a person's, here's a slide about eye and eye deficiency at breast cancer,
but if we looked at a person's zinc and copper, and their zinc copper ratio,
and that was not where we wanted it to be.
This is an example of a normal test there.
I thought, well, what the heck, I'm going to create my own thing, you know, I did.
So I created a zinc DMSO topical solution.
This is, you can't see it, but it's a spray bottle that you could spray it on an area.
Now, if I had prostate cancer, is it going to go as deep at the prostate?
No, it's not.
But if I have a cancer in a bone, a rib, a lug, would it go that deep?
Yeah, it could.
It certainly can't hurt you.
So DMSO is widely used as an anti-inflammatory.
So that's, there is a wrong with use of DMSO in zinc.
There is really no toxic load of zinc though.
I don't have the exact milligrams, but probably per spray.
It's only about five milligrams of zinc, maybe at the highest in what you'd absorb as maybe what.
So this is another solution that I'm going to introduce definitely to my breast cancer patients
that I want them to spray right out their breast right over the tuber and just rub it in.
It just feels like a water.
The only negatives with DMSO is it smells kind of garlicky,
and you could get a oistery garlicky taste in your mouth afterwards,
because it literally can absorb in a minute and you could get that taste in your mouth.
I, of course, tried it up myself and did it on a bunch of areas on my body
and I didn't get that taste at all.
But so I think it depends on the quantity that you use.
But this is another solution to increase zinc stores.
The problem with zinc is you could take it orally too, and I recommend that.
But I recommend a whole food zinc.
That's the zinc liver chelate by standard process.
I don't have a picture of that, but that's a whole food source of zinc.
But do you, when you absorb zinc,
is it going right to the cancer site?
That's, that's the argument and, you know,
how much of it is getting right to the cancer?
I don't know, you know, you probably not a great amount.
So is it good to take zinc orally?
Yes, it would be good to take zinc orally,
but we had to figure out another way to get it to the cancer site.
And besides injecting it using a DMSO
topically, it's the next best solution in my mind.
Does anybody else has any other ideas?
Let me know.
So this is our new zinc DMSO topical.
I just put it up on the website.
It made a dozen or so with these today.
So that's going to be available soon.
So look at it.
I and I levels and I always want my patients
to have higher I and I levels than what is in the normal range.
I think the normal urinary iodide is like 100 to 300.
I will, my patients over 200 at least to maybe 500.
And it's really easy to supplement iodide.
And you only want to use an organic kelp-based iodide.
So if you have iodide at home,
a lot of people use that lugal solution.
I don't suggest that.
The lugal solution is potassium iodide.
I'd rather have you have an organic food-based iodide,
which would be a kelp-based iodide.
It just works much better in the body.
And it's just better for you.
It's very easy to get anywhere.
We have it in a product called selenobeth iodide.
It has selenium in it too, which you need for cancer as well.
Enzymes used.
There was some questions about using enzymes.
It is there are times to use enzymes and not use enzymes.
So the two uses of enzymes for anyone is to help digest food.
Because dietary enzymes are made to help digest proteins.
The enzymes are dietary enzymes that are secreted into your small
attested are made in your pancreas to help break down proteins.
That's part of digestion so that you could absorb amino acids.
So a person could take enzymes with each meal to help their digestion.
But usually that's not what we're talking about with cancer.
We're using enzymes to break up biofilms,
to break up the biofilm around the cancer itself,
and to help allow T cells,
that's your natural killer cells, to attack the cancer.
So therefore you wouldn't take them with your food.
You would take them out of more of an empty stomach.
So taking enzymes in the morning or taking enzymes right when you wake up at an empty stomach,
or taking enzymes right before you go to bed are a good time to take enzymes.
But if you, if we don't have you on enzymes, I didn't recommend those.
I tested you on them and you don't need to take them.
But, but if you are taking enzymes, those, that's when you would use enzymes.
Is there a time when you want to refrain from taking enzymes?
Typically not.
Enzimes are made everywhere in your body, just so you know.
So enzymes, that's what genes code for, they make enzymes.
And they have all sorts of different functions.
So either that's not what we're taking when we're taking them orally.
We're taking ones that will help break down slime layers
and get rid of biofilm that is the waste that's around the cancer or help break down food.
And then I, if you have not watched the video on the new IVG test coming up,
I am super pumped about that as displayed on that video.
Because it's going to give us a real objective data,
one of the things that my patients have asked for for many years
is how do I know I'm getting better?
And I've always said the only way to know is to compare apples with apples.
If, if you did a CT test to find out you have cancer,
you really have to do it other CT test to see if the cancer is going away or not.
And well, we don't want to do that because that's highly invasive.
It's high in a lot of radiation.
It's costly.
Well, the IVG test is going to give us some objective data
that's not going to only be qualitative, but it'll be qualitative.
So it's going to give us a score.
So if my score like this example was 40,
that would be a positive score for cancer.
In a medium to high risk, it's there.
And I do another test in three months and it's a 35.
I'm going the right direction.
If I do another test in three months and it's 60, I need to change something.
So it gives us good data, whether it's called the right direction or the wrong direction
of whether we need to change something or we just need to stay the course.
So that's the benefit of the IVG test that's coming out.
And the one of the, I spoke with the US director of that this weekend.
And he thinks that conservatively speaking in five years,
this may replace a lot of biopsies because the inherent danger of a biopsy,
you know, is that it could help spread cancer.
Well, this is completely not invasive and it's very cost effective.
And it will probably only get more cost of effective over time.
So this test is going to be about between $400 and $500,
which is a fair price to pay for not finding out where you are with your cancer.
So it's another dice objective test that I'm really excited about.
That I know a lot of people are going to want to do.
Now, will that be just in your office or you could order a clinic?
So you could order the kit from us.
You could go to other clinics that are going to use that test,
but it has to be probably a clinic that's kind of specializing in cancer.
The clinic can charge whatever they want for the test.
We're going to just charge our cost.
So we'll send you the kit.
You have to go get a blood draw and you can get a blood draw from any blood station
or a local hospital.
They said the kid in, they spent the blood down, they said the kid in.
You leave and we get the results back at about a week.
And is that appropriate for lines cases as well or just cancer?
No, this is just cancer.
Okay.
So this is not live.
This is only cancer.
Okay.
So this is a cancer risk test.
This is testing for where you're at with your cancer.
So if I below 10, you are having a party.
Okay.
Yeah, without without too much cake.
No sugar cake.
So if you haven't told me for very long, I might frustrate you because I'm always coming up with something new.
So in the event that you don't like change, you probably won't like me.
So I like to constantly be researching and adding new things and studying and figuring it out a new way to help people.
So I have several new therapies that we're adding to our office.
This year has been a big year for adding new therapies.
We added the acoustic therapy, which unfortunately, if you're not a local patient, you can't really take advantage of that.
But this therapy, it's called Sequix that I'm really excited.
It's out of Italy.
So this is not in the US yet.
We, I think, will be, I think one of the first clinics in the US that have this.
I think there is one other clinic.
It's a doctor that I know that has it out of the east coast, but he practices.
Kind of the whole of the wall.
It doesn't let anybody know that he exists because he's afraid of what could happen.
But I'm afraid of what could happen.
So I don't know why, but God's protected us.
This is really cool technology that is something that people could use at home too.
So you're all familiar with the PEMF, the pulse, the electromagnetic field therapy that we use in our office.
We use the pulse brand of that, which is very high frequency PEMF machine.
Well, this is a different type of, you could think of it as a PEMF, but it's not really a PEMF.
It is a frequency machine that's using electrical frequency in a pad.
And it is programmed to your body.
So because it's not light frequency, we scan you.
You lay on this pad and we connect you to these electrodes and we scan you for your nine top frequencies.
And there are about 30 different frequency types.
If you are into physics, you have sine wave frequency, square wave frequency,
sawtoots frequencies, a whole bunch of different types of frequencies.
So this machine scans you over those frequency types.
And it comes up with the top nine different frequencies.
And then we encode a card with that frequency set that we're going to use for you.
And then we treat you with it if you're at our office.
But many people have asked, can I get a PEMF unit for home?
And the struggle is they're very expensive.
The cheapest that I found is the $7,000.
What did I've had multiple people buy it?
I think it's a really good machine.
This is going to be about $4,500 and we can encode it and print it for the frequencies that you need.
That every time you come back to visit us, let's say every three months, we can scan you again and give you a new card.
So as your body changes, we give you a new program that you'll use and you can use it every day.
And it's typically about a half hour program and you just lay on it and you don't feel very much.
I did it at the seminar a couple of times.
The second time I fell asleep within two minutes and she had to wake me up.
It was a little embarrassing, but it was so relaxing.
I said, I'm getting this.
I tell you, I don't know what it's doing, but I feel great.
I'm getting this and this would be great for patients.
So the struggle is more, I can't afford another $7,000 piece of equipment.
This falls much more affordable for people.
We may even rent them out.
I haven't decided that yet, but we're going to try to make it affordable just for another tool for people.
And certainly local patients can commit and do it.
So I'm super excited about this new thing and it's going to be, it's going to be really cool.
So it's going to be another nice piece of equipment for our office.
Any questions on that?
Have that now at the office?
We are, they are delivering it up next Wednesday.
So you're going to be here.
So when the ladies coming to deliver it and set us up and go through a training.
So you're going to be able to experience it like.
So that's, that's pretty cool.
We're excited about that.
Another new piece of equipment that we're getting is, is plat,
a platysmography, that is a study of your vascular health.
And you go, what does this have to do with cancer?
Well, it doesn't have a lot to do with cancer, because it has to do with bringing oxygen to the tissues.
And I have said this multiple times before, just because I have a disease doesn't need that I can't have more than one.
So just because I have cancer doesn't mean I have a perfect heart and I have perfect blood sugar.
And I have perfect kidneys and I have perfect everything else.
Usually if I have a serious disease, it was the result of some other things going on that could affect other organs.
And I can have, I have the right to have more than one thing going on at the same time.
And we have used, um, autonomic testing on every one of you.
And we measure the sympathetic, parasympathetic balance, but that's all we measure with that test.
This new piece of equipment is going to measure sympathetic, parasympathetic balance, but it's also going to measure your blood vessel health.
So that's going to be the elasticity of your arteries.
How well it's carrying, your arteries are carrying oxygen, give you a very good data on whether you have any, any cardiovascular health issue, any blockage of our arterial flow.
And there's, there's seven node types of vascular health and it will put a person in whatever percentage type it is.
This would not be normal for a person to be 100% type two, but it'll put a person in a percentage of where they're at and give you a risk factor.
And that would give us some data whether we want to move forward with getting you in to see a cardiologist to or
getting a lipid panel done or or whatever else that we want to get done to look a little deeper on that, because that can be a factor with both
lime and cancer if we can't oxygenate a tumor, we can't kill a tumor.
So somebody asked a question, why would you do hyperbaric chamber with cancer because it increases oxygenation of the tissue.
And if we can oxygenate a tissue, always say, oxygenated tumor is a happy tumor, but it is going to not be able, it's going to be happy, it's not going to grow anymore.
So if we can oxygenate a tissue cancer, it's going to kill the cancer.
So if we can't oxygenate it because we have nitric oxide issues, we have vascular issues.
There's different things that we could do to support the vessels from a natural perspective to help increase oxygenation, but we really want to have something that we can measure first.
And this will help us without doing a scope on your arteries, this will help us measure it.
So this is not like I would say new information that's new data.
It's just a device that's been out for several years.
I actually looked at it for the last couple of years.
It's very pricey and I thought, well, see, you know, how is it going to completely relate to cancer.
But the more you study at oxygenation of cancer, and this is just going to be another nice tool for us.
So this will be incorporated on everybody's exam and re-exam.
So if you come back to get another re-exam, we'll be testing it.
It's actually really simple, but it's the technology that's in the computer system that gives us the complexity of the test.
So this is going to be another nice test we'll be adding on your re-exam.
And what's that test called again, Dr. Conner's?
It's called Pless' Bography.
Well, that's our sample.
You're going to say that three times fast.
Yeah, yeah, really.
Okay.
David, could you use that?
Yes.
You're still trying to figure out this.
This is called the acting that's happening with me, so we could talk about that.
Yeah, well, you just need to move to Minnesota.
Yeah.
Don't you want to come to Boston?
I do. I do want to come to Boston.
That would be fun.
Well, but yeah.
All right, deal.
Okay, I've got that down.
So any other questions?
I have a quick one.
If I'm going to make a journey to a technician who has Paul selector magnetic frequency service.
How long of an appointment would I ask for?
You want to do it for an hour?
One hour.
Yeah.
Yeah, I do it for an hour.
Do they have the pulse?
They do.
And they could, you could have them call our office and ask what frequency we read.
You wanted everything and where we place the pad.
Oh, good point.
Okay.
So we want to be in contact with your, your, you know, your local doctors that are doing things.
So have them, you know, then we can co-tree to that.
It's always benefits for you.
Okay.
Okay, sounds good.
So how do you know?
How does a Lyme patient know if they're getting better?
How does a Lyme patient know you're getting better?
Well, the easiest way for a Lyme patient is totally go off your symptoms.
Because part of the Lyme is identified in the first place in the blood work.
And you're, you're really, you're going off of your symptoms when you're, you're measuring your success.
Okay.
So if your energy increases and you're starting to, you know, your fatigue is decreasing and you can start living your life a little bit and you're starting to feel like you get your life back.
You know, you're waiting the battle.
Awesome.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right. Well, we are away past our time.
I'm open to state for more questions. If you have them.
I have one more.
Uh-huh.
Do you, I've, we, I've got a bunch of test results done with, uh, with my doctor here who supports you and knows you.
And, uh, should I send those to you before we meet so you can look them over?
Yes, that'd be good. If you could email them to the meet, that'd be great.
Great. Okay.
All right. So I'm going to save this recording. It'll be up on Facebook in the next 20 minutes or so.
And, um, make sure you email me your questions that you have so we could make sure we get them addressed every week.
All right. You guys have a Merry Christmas.
If I don't see you again, make sure you look at Facebook and watch the videos that are on there and make comments and ask questions that you have to.
And have a very, very Christmas.
Thank you.
Merry Christmas to you.
You as well.
Thank you.
Bye.